wait do we have thoughts about us the
oscars
oh yeah
that was pretty boring
just a bunch of people getting awards
and stuff you know coda best picture
yeah
that's all that happened right denzel
was nominated for the macbeth whoever
three people saw that movie
like who would watch that movie i
genuinely didn't even know that
it's black and white it's macbeth no
thank you
really yeah
uh i thought amy schumer was good on the
roster what else happened
i noticed it that's it right nothing
weird happened george dude when i told
you about it did you see it after that
oh of course i watched everything were
you stunned
it was pretty shocking and i've tried to
like i've i've tried to hit it from
every angle
yeah here's the deal um
i mean obviously in the beginning when
it for when i first saw it i was like
yeah
because he bumped me twice no chris rock
rock friday and saturday i wasn't able
to
no he's a nice guy i'm just saying there
was a little problem was like dad you
know don't bump
you know i mean and then eric made a
little meme
of the celebrities that don't be bumping
people into or i mean so um
which is funny but when you really think
about it because there was a moment
um
after
will said don't ever [ __ ] talk about
my couple times he said that
um
where chris
i know that look because i've been there
it's a moment of shock
and trauma
it was traumatic
um he was assaulted
um in front of millions and trillions of
people i mean
not millions of people
watch the but
virally i mean you're talking about the
world side
the whole world russians putin saw it i
betcha martin putin
sanski maybe not because he's fearing
for his life but um
it was assault and um it was a he he has
issues
that's a man with issues
there's an issue there we all have
issues but that's his was just front and
center stage think think
right
you're sitting in the front row right
you have mel gib when mill gibson looks
at you and like you crazy dog you have a
[ __ ] problem you see mel gibson like
you know what i mean that's crazy but
you think it's just like method acting
gone too far with um you know king
richard because he was that type of like
tiger dad
maybe he never got out of that
tiger dad mode
no
because you know you're the oscars you
know
you have all your peers in front of you
he you know will smith has been famous
for a very long time right right he
knows what it all means okay he knows
what it's like in his personal life
going to a mall he doesn't go to omaha
he's never he's never been told he's
that famous right
he understands that he's been to the
oscars many many times before he's been
nominated before right he understands
how many people are watching i mean he
understands all of it the environment
you know
it's like
like even if i
saw i mean i i have dudes that i hate if
i saw like the pope was making a speech
and that dude was next to him the guy
that i hate
even if i had a shot you know i mean i
had a gun i wouldn't do it because it's
like it's next to the pulp
you know what i mean that's a terrible
no baby i'm not gonna analyze i'm sorry
give me another let me give you another
shot yeah
i don't know i'm not gonna analyze i'm
not gonna do another analogy right i
have a question do you think that they
should have escorted him out after that
what i would have liked is
had um
denzel win it
and then you see he sees it in this
scribble with the snake
like a kid's letter denzel you know
whatever somebody wrote it real quick
yeah but denzel is sort of like
he's got like a james baldwin vibe of
him he's very articulate he's very wise
sage he's like a sage yeah
um
i don't know what was that thing that he
said to will smith
something like the devil will get you
the devil will get you when you're at
your highest or something like who says
that that doesn't make any yeah what did
you think of his whole speech after
everything cool uh wills well like when
he was like his whole life rambling
speech about like
how he's a protector and that's why he
hits people
um here's my thing about like
people saying oh like wasn't it so great
that he protected his woman like for me
let me fight my own battles like i don't
need you
to
come to my defense if my
choice if my action in that moment is to
oh cringe not like the joke sit down i
don't need you to like
you know what i mean get all macho and
then slap a dude for me like it makes me
feel worse imagine me and collide are in
the audience we'll never go there but
we'll never yeah
and chriska look at kalyala with her
heart defect or something right yeah
and people are laughing right there's
something worse about my um my um the
way i look not so much stanley bobby lee
is dating stanley tucci oh god stanley
tucci is here right right
and i kind of laugh
right and i look over and you're upset
right
i would look what if you said this even
worse okay go ahead
i'm in the audience yeah
she looks so much like stanley tucci he
hasn't [ __ ] her in two years
no you have to look upset
then i look back up here
and i look at you and i'll go
[Laughter]
we're on tv smile [ __ ]
we're on tv [ __ ]
there's billions of people [ __ ] we're
millionaires [ __ ]
you mean you can take that that's true
he he's here's a guy
who
you you literally get out of touch
you know it's like
i have a theory okay
chris rock is not out of touch
and the reason why he's not out of touch
is because chris rock out of the 30
years i've been doing standup has always
done the comedy store
right there are comics that won't do it
they don't come back and then when they
do show up they have weird people around
them and they don't go you know i mean
and one example is and he deserves the
kind of mystique that he has eddie
murphy now okay
netflix gave him a bunch of money to do
was special right
now i don't it might be the most amazing
thing you've ever seen but you know i
honestly believe
that he might be a little too out of
touch to do it you know
and the material that he has it's just
you have to live a normal life to have
life experiences for people to relate to
it right like chris is always at the
clubs
yeah i've never seen bill and that's not
that bill bird's at that level or even
chris is at eddie murphy's level because
they've never had his kind of movie
career right
no you don't i don't want to
wait i'm leaving come on what were you
gonna say what's dumb
the dum-dums who think that it's uh that
was rehearsed or faked
really so
what's
what what's the point of that
why would they like when sasha baron
cohen did a prank
remember where it was like
um charlie chaplin's
co-star or something who's like 90 years
old now and he pushes her off stage oh
yeah tumbles right that's obviously a
bit right it got a laugh it's
controversial it's edgy but it's funny
it really is funny the way they did that
right
with this one it's like really you think
first of all for them to
these award shows
you think that they just that was the
first time they went up on stage
they have rehearsals during the day
right
they have all the presenters come out
this is your mark you need to come after
that it's not just improvise so the
whole thing is rehearsed right there's a
director producers they're all sitting
around right and it's like chris is
doing his thing will isn't even probably
even there during the rehearsals because
he's just getting he's just nominated
right so he's just sitting there right
see he wouldn't even be there for
rehearsals so what you're saying to me
is that chris calls will smith one night
and goes come over to my house let's do
you you know i'm gonna make fun of your
wife she's gonna look offended right
and then you slap me and wilson is like
why
just do it it's gonna be great i'm a
comedian you know right and then you're
gonna sit back and go don't [ __ ] talk
[ __ ] about my wife
don't ever talk [ __ ] about [ __ ]
whatever right yeah
that's what they came up with well what
about with people saying oh like you
know they did it for ratings i made the
oscars relevant again no no they did it
for ratings because number one um
there's nothing there's not a place more
woke
right than the oscars they're a bunch of
woke little pansies right so it's like
that's the
opposite of walk what they did also it's
like why would he
like voluntarily jeopardize his career
he's he's his career
is not done i mean he mel gibson keeps
working yeah but there's a stink i
haven't seen a mel gibson movie since
that tirade
some of them i've wanted to watch and i
bought them i just can't watch them but
my point is is this you're supporting
them you're right the santa claus
won't look really big but i never
i gave him the money all right but my
point is is that um
yeah it's it doesn't make any sense
that's not how it works right i've never
been to the oscars but i've been to the
billboard award i've been to a bunch of
award shows the mma awards with randy
couture my point is is that you know as
a presenter and stuff you're rehearsing
you have to show up there that you have
to know what to do it's there's no way
that they did that i think my best
theory on it is
if it was faked chris rock would have
had a lot better joke for that moment
right because he he there was even a
part where he was like all right like i
won't say it anymore like he was
flustered for a bit a bit you know but
he's also not no like okay i could see
andy kaufman doing it right but but
there would be no unless it was bob
zamuda in the audience you know what i
mean coming up there would no one else
would do that right so you know chris
rock isn't an andy kaufman-esque
performer he's just not because the only
any kaufman humor is only the two people
that are doing it are in on it right
that's what makes it cool you know what
i mean but that's not what chris rock is
about chris rock is a joke oriented
punchline oriented comic right that that
pause of like
let if it was sasha baron cohen
it could you know i could see theories
you know i mean i might be able to get
behind some theories
but chris isn't that guy you know right
so it's just like it's absurd it's
ridiculous it's not
i just yeah i hate people with
conspiracy theories it's like
none of it's [ __ ] real man i have a
question
none of it's real it's like shut the
[ __ ] up
would you have been able to to um
withstand that open hand slap no i would
have my eyes would have fluttered
you'd only see white right
right i'd probably make another
you know what i mean and i would
directly fall right and the fall would
wake me back up but i would stand back
up and there would be blood dripping
right now from my ears and my back of my
neck right because of the right and it
had blood in my hand i go
we're cutting to a commercial break a
geico or something right all right and
then walk off stage
i really want to know what you would say
okay here we go yeah yeah
okay yeah as i'm walking towards you
yeah yeah what are the five fingers say
to the face
what slap
oh
oh man
um
will smith just slap me
i would say what he said yeah there you
go
anyway the next presenters
like i would go right to the prompter
there's a prompter uh-huh i mean my
instinct would go right to what because
i wouldn't be thinking at that point so
you would just go autopilot yeah yeah so
the the nominees for best documentary
would be
yeah
taylor goldwyn for you know what i mean
amazon princess or whatever right and
people would be like
dude address that he just slapped you
yeah and then and i would get off stage
and i would go right to twitter
no first i would be like abby would be
there my man and i would scream at her
yeah i told you this wasn't a good idea
oh everyone wants to hit me you know
what i mean or whatever right
or i know you know what i would say you
know i honestly unless not no jokes
i would probably go what happened
to people
if i was there yeah
i would go after will smith
if he slapped you i could see oh i would
grab
oh i would run across and [ __ ] i
would absolutely smack i would try to
fight him you knew he'd be scared who
the guy is standing next to sitting next
to stanley tucci because they'd be like
steli stanley tucci
like it would be like it would be like
what the [ __ ] you're so [ __ ] up
i just i just declared that i would
i would defend you i mean it would be a
confusing moment of like a double take
like well this shows
the special effects
in this show
is amazing
did that do makeup you know be nominees
do that makeup or whatever it's funny
though babe come on i know yeah yeah
anyway that person would be scared but
my point is you'd run across and what
i would honestly cause a commotion you
don't [ __ ] hit i if if you got hit by
anybody i don't care if it's will smith
god himself whatever the [ __ ] were to
hit you i here's but here's
the truth of it
and this is because you're a sensible
person right
you're you would feel that inside right
your instincts would be like what the
[ __ ] right but you still would be very
aware of where you are
but if your eyes were white
and i just saw the [ __ ] oh yeah
escape
first right
and you know it would be like you know
that one you're right i would just be
like are you okay sweetie yeah and i'd
be i'd point at him like no [ __ ] you
i probably wouldn't try to fight him
you're right you wouldn't
i mean because you're looking in the
audience you see meryl streep you see
everybody right yeah you probably wave
i'm on tv or whatever
yeah but it would be like i think it
would the photo would be infamous
it's like remember the 60s when this
that school college shooting
and one student got shot and there was a
bystander holding him you'd be one of
those shots you know i mean
you'd be like an iconic
photo
i feel like licks would come out make
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'd just go off on him
and i'm like i'd be by the mic too
because your your body is still by the
mic i pulled a mic and i would just like
call will smith all sorts of names
or somebody would yell out do your lines
from the core
[Laughter]
and then the
audiences
and they're like he's like sean penny
like
you know he's everywhere
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
don't do that because it would it would
freak people out
it would freak people
especially if he wasn't there
what do you mean if tucci wasn't in the
audience just let's just literally
theory yeah i didn't know this turned it
but this would turn into
a immediate oh sorry i'm sorry
you're beautiful babe it's just for the
podcast i say it you know what i mean i
do look like stanley no you don't you
look beautiful baby i do look like sammy
but i accept it no it's just a joke babe
you don't i know it irritates you that's
what i say it doesn't irritate me i
think it's actually um you don't look
nothing like him very very hurtful yeah
you know nothing nothing like him
doesn't irritate me just hurts me deeply
um
that what is
you know but you know i have to say
my last final thing
is
what
why
this is the final thing this is and it's
not a joke okay
is
chris rock is
you know he is like the mon rushmore of
comics
like if you like of today like if there
was a mount rushmore
you'd be chappelle chris rock would be
up there of today you know bill burr
maybe or
whatever you know i mean louis cable
with his dick out whatever you know what
i mean but um
he would they would be up there right
and if you could
assault
one of the mount rushmores of comics we
we're all [ __ ]
we're all [ __ ] you know i mean because
it's like
um our job
as a comedian is to say things that
you're not always going to agree with
is to open the envelope you know i mean
especially for someone like me i'm a
shock comic i just say [ __ ] up things
on stage right
and i i sometimes improvise and say
things that are just like
i i'll sometimes even say something
where i'm like ah why would you say
that's crazy you know i mean but that's
just the whole point of it right and
it's it there's always
comedy clubs and stages of any kind
right if you're doing a play right it's
it should be the safest place
one can be in especially you know when
you're performing it's like you know
imagine if like you're at a
circusolation like love or something
right
and you know you've done the routine a
thousand times and then one day somebody
just shoots you you know when you're up
on one of those rafters right it's just
like it's just like not
cool especially
will smith should know better he's a
performer
he knows that that's a sacred line you
don't cross
that's a really
[ __ ] up thing he did man
it's [ __ ] up i would love him on the
podcast
and i would suck his dick but um
but i'm uh you know i'm a [ __ ]
i really i'm a [ __ ] that's in on that
now all right i want him on tiger belly
jim if you're listening i'll i'm
offering up my body i'm offering i'll
suck
um
but um
what a weird part of that was a cool
party i'm glad we went though
it was keegan's birthday party oh yeah
yeah ron
like